want to elaborate a little bit on my comments
yesterday about the Republican Party crumbling
under Donald Trump and Trump really losing
everything for the Republican Party with a
focus not on evaluating the virtue or morality
of any particular individual Republican, because,
as I told you, they all deserve the repercussions
of sticking by Trump for ninety nine point
nine percent of the presidency.
But I think that we are going to see a six
month period into Joe Biden's transition that
will really be unlike anything we've seen
before.
I know Donald Trump often says this is like
nothing we've seen before.
This really is like nothing we've seen before.
We have never had a situation where during
a global hundred year pandemic, we have a
president made a one term president who refuses
to accept that they actually lost Insight's
dozens of bogus lawsuits and a violent, riotous
insurrection that leads to a temporary delay
in the counting of the electoral votes, gets
suspended from multiple social media networks
for essentially praising the violence, saying
the Protei understands why the protesters
did what they did.
This is what you get when you steal an election.
Donald Trump saying on Twitter before Twitter
deleted that we have never had a situation
like this.
And so we are seeing Mitch McConnell, the
absolutely horrible Senate majority leader,
lose his position as Senate majority leader,
likely to be replaced by Democrat Chuck Schumer
as Democrats take control of the Senate thanks
to the two runoff victories in Georgia by
Raphael Warnock and John OSF on Tuesday night
into Wednesday morning.
And you also are going to see at the same
time that Republicans lose control of the
Senate.
You see them very much on the defensive, having
to either denounce or jump in with or explain
away this riotous insurrection that took place
on Wednesday at a time when we so desperately
need leadership at a time when the economy
is as precarious as it's ever been.
We had I wondered six days ago, will we get
to 4000 coronavirus deaths a day?
Well, on Wednesday, we had forty one hundred
as the violent insurrection was taking place
and Donald Trump was getting banned from Twitter
and Facebook as all that was going on, we
passed for the first time.
Four thousand coronavirus dead in one day.
In fact, the number I believe was was forty
one hundred.
So what is going to be the role of the Republican
Party in the next two years?
What is going to be their role as we we hopefully
start to see vaccination help tamp down the
pandemic in a more permanent way?
Are they going to do what we've suspected
for a long time, which is sort of kind of
pretending they were never really with Trump,
even if they were and going back to we can't
afford this.
And what about the dead?
And we need to be constitutional conservatives
and financial conservatives.
What exactly is going to be there?
What exactly is going to be their approach?
And in a very practical sense, Joe Biden said
earlier this week, two thousand dollar stimulus
checks are riding on the Georgia elections.
Democrats got the two Georgia elections.
Are we getting two thousand dollar stimulus
checks now?
Democrats have control will will have control
of the House, Senate and White House.
And they've been talking about two thousand
dollar stimulus checks.
Democrats in the House and Senate have said
they're OK with two thousand dollar stimulus
checks.
So is that going to happen?
Are we going to see to what degree?
And I am not yet.
Taking a position, I want to think about it
more, to what degree is a Biden administration
potentially with Attorney General Merrick
Garland and control of the House and Senate
to investigate whatever the hell they want?
To what degree are the Trump crime family's
wrongdoings going to be investigated?
There are a lot of compelling arguments to
be made one way or another about the investigation
of former former president in the United States.
But what do that these next two years look
like?
Do Republicans manage to become acute obstructionists?
Do they sort of act like normal people for
a little bit?
Is it conceivable and I know this is so it's
almost naive and cliché to say, but do a
few reasonable, reasonable Republicans that
saw the error of Trump Trump's ways, like,
you know, the perpetually disappointed Susan
Collins and Mitt Romney who voted to to convict
on one of the two articles of impeachment.
Do they join Democrats in the Senate so that
it's not 50/50 if Joe Manchin is OK with a
tie breaker by Kamala Harris, but maybe it's
52 48 on some of these key issues?
Would Susan Collins and Mitt Romney go for
some some, you know, green energy infrastructure,
deal with some teeth to it?
I don't know.
I don't know the answers.
But what we do know is that Donald Trump has
lost everything for the Republican Party losing
than the House in twenty eighteen, losing
them, the Senate and the White House in 2020.
The Republican Party, in a sense, is crumbling,
but we know from history is very resilient
and has voters who are very willing to say,
oh, Trump's gone.
We're back to we care about the debt and deficit
and blocking abortion again and, you know,
religious freedom or whatever.
We know they're eager to get back to that.
And so the next two years are a real question
mark.
I think Joe Biden's first 100 days will tell
us a lot about how that's going to go.
Let me know what you expect.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman